ايران في دائره الضوء من جديد في اجتماع
مجلس محافظه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رغم انشغال الوكاله الدوليه بالوضع
في اوكرانيا ومحاولتي تامين المواقع
النوويه هناك في المجلس يناقشه للمره
الثانيه في اقل من سته اشهر مشروع قرار
يدين رفض تعاون ايران في تحقيق الذي فتحته
الوكاله قبل اربع سنوات بعد العثور على
اثار يورانيوم في مواقع سريه التقرير الذي
رفعه مدير الوكاله يعبر عن قلقا متزايد
وما يبدو انه صبرا بدا ينفذ
لا يمكن الاستمرار لاشهر وسنوات من دون
تقديم تفسير عندما يكون هناك تفسير يجب
اعطائه بحسب الواجبات لن اتحدث عن مهل
زماني ولكن لا يمكن الاستمرار بهذا الشكل
للابد
كاملا للثقه في ايران في حال بقيت مو صراع
على رفضها تقديم اجابات حول نشاطاته
السريه
من مصلحتهما العمل معنا وكما قلت سابقا لا
اجنده سياسيه للوكاله الدوليه نحن نؤدي
عملنا وهم واجبهم الرد المندوب الامريكي
في مجلس المحافظين انتقد شرط ايران اغلاق
التحقيق للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي مشيرا
الى ان واجباتها لا علاقه لها بالسياسه
تزداد الضغوط السياسيه على ايران للتعاون
مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التي
تتمسك برفضها اغلاق التحقيق لغايه الحصول
على اجوبه وتنتظر الوكاله الان توضيحا من
طهران حول زياره قريبا الى ايران لبدا
الحصول على هذه الاجوبه
رغبهم العربيه في الجنه